Hey, we are bring science down to earth.
What is this, Neil?
This is Wheel of Science.
(fun music)
Hey everybody, I'm Chuck Nice.
Welcome to our newest show, Star Talks,
Wheel of Science.
This is an interactive show
where we answer your questions about the universe.
And because I'm not smart enough
to even answer my own questions about the universe,
we have here to help out,
the one, the only,
your own personal astrophysicist,
Dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson.
What's up Neil?
What's up Chuck?
As usual, you don't know the questions.
That's right.
I'm sitting here clueless.
Ah ha, but I'm positive that you know the answers.
Our topic today is
black holes.
Let's do this, bring it on.
Hey Neil, before we get into it,
can you just let the people know
what is a black hole.
Black hole is a region of space
where matter has condensed to such a high density
that the gravity at it surface,
the surface gravity,
is so high that you cannot escape it
even at the speed of light.
You are forever trapped.
It is the fabric of the space time continuum
warped back on itself.
And once you fall in,
you are never coming out.
It is the human version
of the roach motel.
(chuckles)
You check in but you don't check out a black hole.
That's why we call them black.
And when you fall in you don't come out,
that's why we call it a hole.
(Chuck chuckles)
'cause we tell it like it is in astrophysics,
black hole.
Spin that wheel.
(game music)
Daniel Junius wants to know:
"What happens when we fall into a black hole?"
Ooh, you want to avoid that first of all.
Never, don't do that.
Neither at home or at work, or anywhere else.
But if you happened to fall in a black hole,
which is my preferred form of death.
It's better than getting hit by a bus.
So, if you fall in at a feet first dive,
to this cosmic abyss,
you will not survive.
Because you will not miss
the tidal forces of gravity
will create quite a calamity
when you stretched head to toe.
Are you sure you want to go?
Those tidal forces
will increase to the point
where your body will just snap in two
likely at the base of the spine.
Then each of those two pieces will snap into two.
So you become one to two, to four, to eight, to 16,
until you bifucate all the way down,
to the center of the black hole.
And you become a stream of atoms.
And that's not even the worst part.
The worst part is you are funneled,
extruded through the fabric of space time.
So that you used to be this wide,
now you are this narrow.
And so, this phenomenon,
this extrusion, like toothpaste through a tube,
we have a word for it.
Death by black hole is called "Spaghettification".
Spaghettification, sounds like a meal to die for. (laugh)
See what I did there.
Kill me.
But give this video a like for a dead joke.
(chuckles)
Chuck.
Alright Neil, are you ready for the next one?
Spin that wheel.
(game music)
Ivica Sur wants to know this:
"There is a black hole in the middle of our galaxy,
"is there a giant black hole, or something giant,
"in the middle of our universe?
"And something in the middle of the multiverse
"if we follow that logic?"
No.
And that's all we have time for.
(laughs)
No. What do you want from me?
It's a no. No.
No.
But I'm suer there's more to it.
What's up?
There is no center of the universe.
All the universe was at the same place at the same time
nearly 14 billion years ago.
Then you could think of it sort of is a center.
But after that we are expanding
and all pieces expanding away from every place else.
It feels like we are at the center,
but we're not
anymore than when you are a ship at sea,
and you are in the middle of you own horizon.
You are equally distanced from every edge of your horizon
doesn't mean you are at the center of anything.
So no.
There is no known center of the universe.
And therefore I can say with some confident that
there is no black hole there.
Okay Neil, thanks for making me feel less important
than I already do
knowing that I'm not the center of the universe.
But wait a minute,
how about black hole at the center of our galaxy?
We've got one,
Andromeda's got one.
Except theirs is bigger than ours.
We have black hole envy,
but that's another show.
Long ago we didn't know if black hole
would be common in the center of the galaxies.
But with the help of Hubble telescope,
which has good precise ways to look down in the center,
every galaxy we've had the capacity to check
has revealed a black hole to us.
Thus we will extrapolate and assert
that a black hole is a natural phenomenon
in the center of all galaxies in the universe.
Neil, as usual, that's fascinating.
We have time for one more question.
And we are gonna take a look at some group comments.
But first, let's spin that wheel.
(game music)
Dan Birmingham wants to know:
"What's the most exciting thing
"we don't know about black holes?"
There's good theoretical ideas
about what would happen if you survive a trip
through the black hole,
and come out on the other side.
All of our equations tell us that
an entire new space time opens up for you.
Once you left the universe you were just in
you will never return to it.
But you will enter another domain.
Our equations tell us it's there.
But there is no way to test that
and come back and tell anybody about it.
So that remains for me
one of the most intriguing mysteries of the universe.
Is each black hole a universe unto itself?
Chuck, back to you.
Damn. That is super cool.
I'm gonna call that a black rabbit hole.
(exciting music)
Well, Neil, we are out of time.
Thanks for being here, buddy.
I'm happy to be with you Chuck, always.
Make sure you subscribe to
StarTalk network on Facebook watch,
and join the Wheel of Science group
and leave comments,
like Brain McReynolds says,
"I have just started sneaking science facts
"onto the dry erase announcement board at work,
"so this will give me some more ideas lol"
Why don't you find Brain and leave him some facts.
Thanks for watching guys.
We'll see you next week on
Wheel of Science.
(game music)